أنا مرعوب من التجول وأنا أتجول وأنا أبدو هكذا
ثم يصرخ الناس في وجهي ،
أنا مدون السفر الخاص بـ
buckelislee.blog
أنا مقيم في تايلاند ولدت
وترعرعت وأنا أفعل هذا منذ
حوالي ثماني سنوات مسافرًا حول العالم.
حول البلدان والوجهات في
بعض الأحيان تشعر بهذا الخوف نوعًا ما
عندما تسافر للخارج لأنك
لست في بلدك الأم
فأنت في موقف محفوف بالمخاطر ومن ثم
هناك هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يأتون
إليك ويلومونك على كل شيء خاطئ
العالم وهكذا ، لدي خوف مثل الأخبار
لم
ترسم صورة جيدة جدًا للمسافرين الآسيويين
من تجربتي ، الأسوأ لم
يأت بعد
يا إلهي ، لا يمكنك أن تقف أمامنا
وتخبرنا أن نعود إلى بلدك
الذي يجردك من إنسانيته ،
هذا كل شيء من الاعتداءات أه إلى
التمييز في مكان العمل ، سمها ما شئت
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالأمريكيين الآسيويين
وهم كذلك.  لقد تم استهدافهم بسبب
فيروس كورونا ،
حيث يتم التعامل معهم بشكل سيء
لأنهم يُلامون على فيروس كورونا.
أنا أستضيف منصة تعليمية رقمية
تعلم
دروسًا مجانية ، إنها تسافر من خلال
التعليم حيث أسافر حول
العالم
لإعادة تعريف الخبير وبث دروس مجانية
عبر الإنترنت
بشكل عام قبل  - لقد قللت من
سفري مع الآسيويين الآخرين لأنني
تعرضت للاعتداء ، فقد تمت
ملاحقتنا ومضايقتنا لكوننا آسيويين ومولعين ومثقفين ، لذا فأنا في
الواقع لا
أسافر مع الآسيويين الآخرين بسبب هذا
الطمع
الآن بعد كوفيد  لا أرى هذا التوقف حقًا
، وإذا لم أكن أتطور إلى اعتداءات أكثر عنفًا ،
فأنا مدون سفر صيني كندي ،
فأنا مؤسس موقع الويب
happytowander.com ،
لذا فأنا أعيش بالفعل في ميونخ بألمانيا ،
أحد الإجراءات الاحترازية التي بدأتها  أخذ
الكاميرا في الواقع يعني أنني لا آخذ
كاميرتي ، عندما أمشي أشعر وكأنك تعرف
كشخص
آسيوي في مدينة غالبية سكانها من
البيض وأنا كذلك  تبدو
مختلفة تمامًا والناس يتساءلون بالفعل ،
حسنًا ، هل هي من هنا
أم أنها من مكان آخر
ولكن ثانيًا أخرج الكاميرا الخاصة بي
أشعر أن هذا النوع من
الصور النمطية للسائح الآسيوي
يخشى
أن الناس قد  النظر إلي
والتفكير فورًا استنادًا إلى ما
يبدو عليه أنني قد أكون
حاملًا لفيروس أو قد يكون من
الخطر أن أكون بالقرب
منك وهو أمر مؤسف للغاية ولكن هذا واقع يواجهه الكثير منا على ما أعتقد
[موسيقى  ]
مرحبًا بكم في اليوم الثاني ،
أراهن أنه لم يكن أحد
سيخمن كمسافر آسيوي ، لقد تعرضت للاعتداء
والتحرش
عندما أسافر لأنهم
ليسوا في حذائي فهم لا يعيشون تجربتي
ولكن إذا قرأوا عنها إذا كنت  أعط
تمثيلًا للمسافر الآسيوي
مثل ، هذا ما أواجهه ،
ثم يتعرضون لذلك ، لذلك
أردت أن أفعل ذلك
لنفسي ولجميع الأشخاص الآخرين الذين
مروا بتجارب جيدة وسيئة ما كانوا عليه
حتى نتمكن من ذلك  مثل كول  المشاركة
والمساهمة بشكل فعال في مساعدة بعضنا البعض
لجعل تلك التجارب أفضل